على مدار سنوات مضت ظلت الامم المتحده
ومنظمات دوريه اخرى تحذر من مخاطر التغير
المناخي ورغم المؤتمرات العديده التي عقدت
منذ قمه الارض في ريو دينيرو عام 92 من
القرن الماضي فان المخاطر ما فتئ التزيد
والاوضاع تسوء اكثر فاكثر فلماذا فشلت قمم
المناخ العديده في الحد من الاثار
الكارثيه لظاهره التغيرات المناخيه وكيف
ستتعامل الدول العربيه مع الاخطار
المتزايده التي تهدد امنها المائي
والغذائي
[موسيقى]
هو اولا يجب التذكير على انه سنه 22 كانت
سجلت ارقاما قياسيه غير مسبوقه هذه حقيقه
حقيقه جاءت لتتوج خمس سنوات كلها عجاف
وخمس سنوات من الجفاف وعدم انتظام
التساقطات ولذلك ليس مستبعدا ولا مستغربا
ان تكون السنوات حتى سنه 2030 تسير على
نفس الوتيره لظاهره النينيو عندما عندما
حدثت افرزت مجموعه من الظواهر هذه الظاهره
تتجلى في انه مياه البحر السطحيه كانت
ترتفع درجه حرارتها بشكل لا يتناسب مع
الوقت ومع الفتره الزمنيه
الارتفاع في درجه الحراره كان ينتج ظواهر
مناخيه
على نوعين ففي السواحل الشرقيه مثلا كانت
هناك امطار طوفانيه
تتطور لكي تصبح عصير او اعصارات هذه
الاشياء مع الاسف هي مرشحه
للاستمرار ولزياده اللهم اذا كانت يعني
الايرادات وكذلك القرارات اصحاب القرار
يجب ان يتخذوا ما ينبغي اتخاذه ان اسيا
وافريقيا ستكون الاكثر تضررا في الفتره
المقبله هل من تفسير ايضا لذلك
مناطق افريقيا واسيا الحقيقه نتيجه يعني
الوضع والفقر اللي موجود في هذا الموضوع
سكانهم والناس ثم قابليه تكيفهم ضعيفه
لذلك اثار التغيرات المناخيه يتوقع ان
يكون عليها اثر كبير على هذه المناطق
[موسيقى]
يعني جدل قديم وحديث ومستمر لان الخبراء
دائما هم يحددون المشكله لكن من الصعب جدا
ان تصل لما يسمى
ولاصحاب القرار حتى تعمل التنفيذ في هذا
الموضوع
اولا ان اتفاق باريس لم يفشل ان اتفاقيه
باريس للمناخ كانت حقبه اساسيه
ومحطه مهمه في مسار نقاش مشكله تغير
المناخ ومواجهه تبعات تغير المناخ ان مسار
مواجهه تغير المناخ حقق تقدما حقق تقدما
في العشرين سنه الماضيه ولكن كانت هناك
مطبات ومن ضمنها مطبات للاسف في في تنفيذ
اتفاقيات باريس اتفاقيه باريس لم تنفذ كما
هي او كانت تنفيذها جزئيا بعده اسباب اولا
لان الاراده السياسيه التي
كررت هنا في باريس عام 2015 لم تنفذ لم
ينفذ قاده الدول تعهداتهم من جهه ثانيا
جائحه الكورونا اتت جائحه الكورونا لتصطدم
بمسار تنفيذ تغير المناخ في اتفاقيه باريس
ان المشكلات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه ايضا في
العامين الماضيا ومن ضمنها الحرب في
اوكرانيا
خلقت صعوبات ايضا
صعوبات جديده في تنفيذ اتفاقيه بريد من
ضمنها ايضا طبعا نكست انسحاب امريكا في
العام 2018 من اتفاقيه باريس
[موسيقى]
المتوسط وخصوصا وخصوصا غرب المتوسط يعاني
من هذه الظاهره اكثر من كثير من الاماكن
في العالم وهذه القضيه ظهرت في عام 2012
بالضبط في الدوره الثامنه عشره لمؤتمر
الكوب الذي عقد هنا في الدوحه
ومن هنالك انا اعتقد انه قد بدا العد
العكسي لهذه الظواهر بدات التساقطات يعني
في في عدم الانتظام بدا يعني مخزون او
رصيد كل دوله
من الماء في التناقص
الوقت الحاضر باستثناء الامطار فليست هناك
ايه امكانيه للتدارك اذا علمنا ان المصادر
الجوفيه للمياه بدورها تعاني فاختفاء هذه
البحيرات وهذه المياه السطحيه ليؤدي الى
انه الحيوانات بمختلف اشكالها وكل السلاسل
التي كانت تعيش فيها او بجوارها من طيور
المهاجره الى الى غيرها من الكائنات
الاخرى بدورها تتاثر وعندما يقع هذا
الاختلال في التنوع البيولوجي ينعكس ذلك
اول ما ينعكس على صحته الانسان
[موسيقى]
اغلب يعني المنطقه العربيه تقريبا 90% او
اكثر من مياهها تاتي من خارج المنطقه
العربيه لذلك هي تعد مناطق هشه لتغيرات
المناخيه حقيقه الان لدينا موضوع شحه
المياه يتصدر المشهد في العراق هي المشكله
الكبرى حاليا في العراق يعني الان ولاول
مره تاتينا ثلاث اربع سنوات جفاف متتاليه
يعني وهذا الحقيقه اثر بشكل كبير على يعني
على على المياه وعلى البحيرات وعلى
الاهوار بشكل عام
اذا اوروبا دخلت الان في زمن تغير المناخ
والمواطنون ليس فقط السياسيون ولكن
المواطنون اصبحوا مدركين لهذا الامر في
اوروبا ان مشكله المياه هي المشكله الاولى
من تبعات تغير المناخ يعني على سبيل
المثال على مستوى الكون في العام 2030
يعني بعد سنه سبع سنوات من اليوم في العام
2030 سوف يكون هناك طلب للمياه على
المستوى الكوني طلب للمياه 40% زائد عما
يمكن ان يكون متاح للانسانيه
هذا يؤخر الوقوع في المحضور بالاساس لانه
عندما تلجا الى التوزيع فهذه مساله
ايجابيه في الاحتفاظ على ما هو متوفر
وموجود ولكن من ناحيه اخرى هو يفرز مجموعه
من الممارسات فقد نوجد في حالات من
التبذير ربما اكثر من الحالات العاديه او
يعتبر ان الخلاص فيما هو قادم ياتي من ما
يمكن تسميته بالمصادر غير التقليديه اي
تحليه ماء البحر ومن جهه اخرى معالجه
المياه العادمه واعاده استعمالها
فهذا يمكن ان يصنف في اطار المقوله انه
مصائب قومي عند قوم فوائد قد تكون ولكن هي
في نهايه المطاف
وحتى اذا ما حدثت التساقطات فطبيعه
المنطقه طبيعه التساقطات طبيعه الساكنه
تتضرر ايضا لان الهيئه الحكوميه المعنيه
بالمناخ في الامم المتحده هيئه الخبراء لم
تلحظ في تقاريرها المتتاليه اي اثار تبعات
ايجابيه او مفيده لتغير المنافذ
[موسيقى]
بالاجراءات فرنسا كما اشرت عندها خطه الان
لمواجهه الجفاف عندها خطه للتقليل هناك
اراضي فرنسيه فيما بعد البحار يعني في
هناك اراضي بدات الان في جداول زمنيه
يقولون للمواطنين في هذا الاسبوع لن
تتمكنوا من الاستفاده باكثر من كذا بالمئه
من المياه العذبه اذا اصبح الان التقنين
وقحتمي في بعض المناطق في اوروبا
قد يكون بالنسبه للدول التي يجمعها تجمعها
احواض مائيه
او تشترك في احواض مائيه مع دول اخرى ليس
واردا فحسب ولانما ضروري
ولكن الدول التي لها مصادرها الخاصه
فقد تكون هناك شراكات وقد يكون هناك تعاون